hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my one twenty haven't done
these in a little while I'm gonna get
real on track and why is that because I
got a new MacBook and that is exciting
one it is black can you see that does
that work
number two the video on my old MacBook
did not work so it didn't allow me up
being on the road all the time to do a
my 120 but this will just got back from
Virginia spoke at the new new internet
was a great time great people there Tim
Farriss Frank Gruber Nick O'Neill Oh
Malik Ryan Carson it was just amazing
time you know and what I really want to
talk about today though is not about
that or anything else it's about
anticipation and how amazing that is you
know I'm sitting here at 308 in the
morning and I need to be at Wine Library
tomorrow and what's really kind of
interesting to me is here's AJ you know
he's chillin with us and you know we're
working on something something cool like
a secret kind of project kind of thing
and that makes it so much fun and that's
what is really so exciting about working
and living and you know whether it's a
movie or something coming out like a
game or the big game or working on a
project that you will see become reality
in a little bit in in my mind hands-down
bar none the anticipation to a date is
far greater than the event the event
rarely lives up to the reality of the
hype and you know I'm a hype kind of guy
I'm into that I believe in that I live
that way and if I can recommend anything
make sure you always hype everything as
much as you can because I think that the
lead-up is so much fun and I always find
myself halfway through the actual event
getting somewhat depressed I'll see you
soon